joining me now is larry kudlow white
house economic advisor uh larry good to
see you tonight
if biden was serious
about empowering american workers he did
the big populist push today
why didn't he actually do that during
his 40-plus years in dc
well that's a good point he had his
chance particularly with obama
last eight years before president trump
uh we had one of the worst recoveries in
history look
you go down the list and look at that
campaign
document first of all he intends to
repeal
every tax cut that president trump put
in
to rejuvenate the economy and let me
make this point
despite the mantra of the democrats that
all tax cuts help the rich
the trump tax cuts did exactly what we
hope
that is middle income blue collar
workers lower wage earners
performed the best not only were they
the lowest unemployment rate in history
but their wage increase was faster than
the top one percent
and the unemployment rates for african
americans and hispanics and asians and
women
were historic lows plus biden's going to
add
new taxes today he said by the way uh he
doesn't want to have a stock market he
doesn't want to have shareholders
involved in the stock market well you
know besides pension funds and even
union pension funds over 51 percent
are invested in the stock market which i
might add is up 40
since the loans he's gonna he's going to
rewrite
all of the regulatory reductions that
president trump put in
to help small businesses it's going to
be enough to hire workers he's a
nightmare
he's for the green new deal he's for the
green new deal which will end he can
talk about coal mines all he wants
but if you go with the green new deal
that means
all fossil fuels gone bye to the energy
sector
larry let me get in here let me let me
get in here because i think what biden
sees
obviously he's at a disadvantage in
arguing these points it's obvious his
whole career speaks to
internationalism and and exporting jobs
to china
but he also can say now because you all
haven't done it
i'm going to bring back drug
manufacturing i'm going to do this trump
says he was
going to do it from china i'm going to
do it why hasn't the trump
administration moved on that
order i know peter navarro and others
have been pushing it was reported today
why are we not bringing back some of
these drugs and bringing them back stack
to use a medical term but that's exactly
what we're trying to do
not only pharmaceuticals but
semiconductors what's holding it up
retailers
well there's nothing holding it up uh we
are when we come out with our
program we're already in discussion with
lots of companies based in china
we had a discussion today a leading
semiconductor company
is selling their factories in china and
coming back home
we will give them the lowest corporate
tax rates we will give them perhaps tax
credits
certainly 100 expensing we may use
some government funds to pay for their
moving costs we have a whole campaign
plan
we're warning american investors not to
invest in chinese stocks because of the
fraudulent accounting
uh robert o'brien and i have already
warned the thrift savings plan
and the railroad retirement fund so we
are doing exactly that
and we're taking steps to deal with this
hong kong disaster
so i don't think it's right to say we
haven't done it we've been doing it
and the tax reform itself we made it so
easy to repatriate
uh profits and capital come back to the
united states
in a second trump term you'll see a lot
more of that and so we you can commit
tonight
that we will bring back these crucial
drugs and the manufacturing even if the
price goes up a little bit
uh at home in order to secure our
stockpile of critical medications
i think laura that we learned
not the only country other countries but
the united states learned
that china is not to be trusted period
full
stop and that we cannot rely on these
long
complicated supply chains coming out of
china
i think you'll see the whole business
community you'll see
business school professors saying now
the supply chains don't work we've got
to bring them back home
because china is not reliable they're
not the only ones who are unreliable
but i hear the same thing from people
around the world so that's going to be a
major change
but we have got to continue
low taxes and deregulation and fair
trade deals if we do that we will come
through this pandemic i think we're
going to get 20
growth in the second half hopefully the
virus hot spots will be
subdued and mitigated and i think we can
have a big bang in 2021.
we were coming into this strong you know
that the tax
cuts weren't the deregulation worked the
energy worked the trade one
we just had the usmca we just had the
usmca
president obrador was here a lot of
goodwill
real quick percentage point to gdp real
real quick isn't it really important
that people understand
comparing our response to covid
to europe's response our economy is
faring
far better than the major european
countries i don't think a lot of voters
know that
but when you look at the charts it's
undeniable trump's policies
post covid are working economically
biden wants to turn that back by
locking us all down as do those democrat
mayors real quick larry
well we look we we have a strong v-shape
recovery there's some recovery in europe
by the way but we do have a strong
recovery let me just say this
in in closing i am concerned about the
virus
hot spots and i will say this if you
want
to reopen our economy if you want to let
the president
rebuild our economy for the second time
the best thing we can do
is take the safety measures use the face
mask the president said that tonight
with sean
keep the distancing the testing is so
important in the hot spots
and personal hygiene if you practice
that then we will stabilize the hot
spots
and we will be off to the races in a
strong economy
that's where we started and it can
continue larry great to see you tonight
thanks so much for joining us